this is an example or rather a story
that's supposed to give us some insight
and some intuition about what the law of
iterated expectations really means
suppose that you work for a forecasting
company and suppose that you make
forecasts by calculating expected values
of the quantities that you want to
forecast and of course when you
calculate an expected value you always
use whatever information you have so
here we have the beginning of the year
and you are working for a company that's
trying to forecast the sales during the
month of February that's a random
variable capital X you're sitting in
your office in the beginning of the year
what is going to be your forecast it's
going to be the expected value of the
random variable X so this is the
forecast that you make at this point in
time now time goes by and we are sitting
now in the beginning of February or the
end of January at that time you obtain
some new information which is the value
little Y of a random variable Capital y
what should your new forecast be well
once you have this information in your
hands your new forecast should be the
expected value of x given the specific
available information that you have so
this is the revised forecast as
calculated at the end of January but if
you are sitting here in the beginning of
the year and you ask yourself what is
the revised forecast going to be your
answer will be I don't know what is
going to be it's random it depends on
what capital y will end up being my
revised forecast is a random variable
the expected value of x given Y which
will take this particular numerical
value if it turns out that the random
variable Y takes a specific value little
Y so this is the forecast calculated at
this point in time
this is the forecast viewed in the
beginning of the year at which time we
do not know yet the value of the revised
forecast now what does the law of
iterated expectations tell us in this
case it tells us that the expected value
of the revised forecast is the same as
the original forecast
what does this mean in practical terms
it means that given today's forecast the
original forecast you do not expect the
next forecast the revised one to be
higher or lower it could be either
higher or lower but on the average you
expect the revision of the forecast
going from this one to that one the
revised one that revision on the average
to be equal to zero
you do not expect forecasts to be
revised either upwards or downwards on
the average of course this is not what
happens always in real life so suppose
that capital X the quantity you're
forecasting is the cost of some big
project and your original budget or
original forecast expected value of x is
what you expect the cost of the project
to be well from experience with real
life we kind of know that budgets or
cost estimates tend to be revised
upwards more often than downwards does
this real-life fact contradict the law
of iterated expectations well not really
what is going on here is that real life
forecasts are not really honestly
calculated expected values but maybe
they're calculated with some implicit or
hidden biases so that the forecasts that
are given are actually not the expected
values so there is no contradiction
between this mathematical fact and
possible life experiences